we say hey to Mary Kay here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Mary Kay I'm
doing great how you doing all right what
happened what happened oh you know what
it was time I mean the New York Giants
are starting to interview people I think
they're probably going to go after a
John Dorsey type of person and I think
the Browns wanted to jump in the game
and make sure that they have a shot at
some of the best GM types in the NFL so
but why would they sour on Shashi brown
I thought this is the process that
they're trusting well the process is
like you said we built it in a 1 in 27
record it has resulted in them passing
on Carson Wentz who could be the MVP
this year he's got a tendancy record
right now they test under Shawn Watson
meanwhile the Rams are still looking for
a quarterback they're only 12 this
season running for owen 16 and the plan
doesn't seem to be working so did we
take this to mean that Hugh Jackson
wasn't part of the process of skipping
over Winston and Watson that's correct I
want a story earlier this week that he
actually preferred went over God in the
2016 draft that was his guy all the way
and and the front office was really
determined to turn that pick that number
two overall pick into a bunch of pics
and try to set this organization up for
sustained success but inadvertently they
passed on you know somebody that could
go down in history as being right up
there with some of the best quarterbacks
in the NFL so let's walk me through this
then so so back in the draft in spring
of last year as the Browns are swapping
spots for the Philadelphia Eagles you
Jackson somewhere in the building saying
don't do it well you know I think he was
putting new back then I think back then
he still really you know believed and
trusted that that fashi Brown and Paul
DePodesta and those guys you know really
did have a firm sound plan that they
knew what they were doing I don't think
he realized at the time just how much
that you know inexperienced they had in
terms of just watching film and picking
guys and evaluating quarterbacks but by
the time that Draft was over it was
pretty evident because they pick Cody
Kessler in the third round they took a
lot of heat for that and they passed on
Carson Wentz and I think by the time
that draft was over the bloom was off
the road and
he who didn't want to Shawn Watson
saying let's take him here he didn't
want that well he'd like to Shawn watch
it I don't know that he stood on the
table for him at number 12 but once
again he didn't have a whole lot of
control in the draft at that point and
they were determined to take that number
12 pick and turn into another first
rounder in 2018 Mary Kate Cabot of The
Plain Dealer cleveland.com joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show I think you
see what I'm driving out here and I'm
not a huge accent hater by any stretch
of the imagination I've met him and
everybody who I know who has who
definitely knows him better than I do
from Mariucci to Mike silver just loves
this guy and thinks that he is gonna be
a great head coach in this league if he
gets the chance but who is going to who
of the dorsey's or the de castas or the
Eliot Wolf's of the world are gonna come
in to Cleveland and and be told you get
to shop the groceries but this is your
coach well you know what I think that
means I think this means that D and
Jimmy Haslem have kind of you know sided
with huge accident that he's probably
going to have some say in who the new
general manager is because everyone
knows that did the coach in the gym have
to be working in lockstep so I would
think that the names that start to crop
up that he will have some history with
them or some relationship with them or
at least approve of them in some way
this is just the last team as I started
the show Mary Kay the last team to do
this was the Jets where Rex days Mike T
goes but John is it comes in and and we
saw all that worked out
it just doesn't these these these these
types of moves don't usually work out
Mary Kay you know what it depends on how
you setup your power structure and I
don't know what their thinking is yet
but if they give you the power over the
53-man roster pit and the 53 that's
always overrated what it means is if
they give you the authority to pick the
players if he's the final say on all of
those players that they pick then you
know then it he could also pick his
general managers you know I mean it's
not like wow you're asking the general
manager to come in and bend it to
whatever he wants if you give him that
power then you know that changes the
power structure a lot well how's it
going
sit in a fan base that seen one in 27
where everybody's accountable right that
how they gonna like the fact that
they're putting all the power now in
Hugh Jackson from what it seems like
Mary Kay I work in Cleveland I don't
know if they will I don't know if that's
the plan to give him to give him those
roster decisions I'm not really sure yet
what they have in mind with that but I
think this is the has ones looking at
this and saying you know what the guy
wanted to quarterback you try he wanted
Jimmy Garoppolo didn't get that one in
Carson Wentz didn't get that wanted a
dream it's a dream Karen that blew up
you know he went into the season without
one quarterback who had ever won a
football game on the roster to who had
never even started one and a bunch of
receivers who just you know weren't very
good so I think the Hansons are looking
at it as though they put a coach out
there on the field to try to coach with
a hand side behind it back and they're
gonna try to change it that's
commendable
I got Mary Kate cabot joining me here on
the Rich Eisen show couple more
questions for you what did happen with
AJ McCarron what happened well you know
what I don't think the front office
really wanted to do that deal I think it
was a huge accident thing I think I
think he pushed for it I think Jimmy
hasn't stepped in and said get it done
and I think that you know it just didn't
happen in time they didn't make the
decision to get it done in time actually
they probably did have the time to
notify the league properly but for
whatever reason they didn't they didn't
notify the league by 4:00 p.m. and it
fell through so if I may is this like
the the the moment you're on an elevator
and you see somebody who wants to get on
the elevator you have the opportunity to
hit the door open button but you just
don't want to is that basically what
just happened you know nobody will ever
really know exactly what the motive was
behind that but most people that I've
talked to seem to think that if you want
to execute a trade and you really want
to get it done that that it's definitely
doable and you can and you can get it
done within moments within a minute you
know it's not that hard to do what you
just described to me insubordination
though Mary Kay that's what I know yeah
you know what I honestly can't say like
I said I don't know what isn't it
the minds and the souls of people but I
don't think that initially the front
office wanted to do that deal they took
too much time and by the time they made
up their mind that they didn't want to
do the deal it just didn't get executed
properly I can't accuse anybody of
sabotaging the deal because I have no
idea if that really happened who's out
with Sascha Brown is deep Podesta know
too you know as of right now everybody
remains intact but I think a lot will I
have to do with what the new guy wants
when he comes in in order to attract a
top quality NFL personnel guy and and to
be able to interview some of the ones
that are with existing teams as they
move through the process here you're
probably going to have to give that guy
a lot of authority and a lot of saying
I've already talked to guys that they
won't set foot in the door here unless
they know that they can kind of clean
house or do whatever they want except
for the coach except for the coach yep
last one for you how does Josh Gordon
look I mean he and Odell Beckham are the
only receivers to get at least 85 yards
on the LA Chargers secondary this year
so that's not a bad start even though
it's difficult sometimes to watch Kaiser
try and get him the ball there was one
remarkably well design play where was I
believe the second half Mary Kay where
there were three receivers out on each
side of the field and it looked to me
specifically designed to get Gordon the
ball and he was open and Kaiser couldn't
do it so my question for you is how does
this gonna look do you think for the for
the rest of the season with Gordon well
hopefully for the Browns take those two
guys we'll get some more timing down
they'll figure each other out a little
bit you know first of all Josh had to
knock a little bit of the rust off he
has to know the route concept and get to
know this offense a little better and
study harder and study film and then
Deshawn Kaiser has to work on his
accuracy he's only completing 52 points
five percent of his passes that's not
going to fly so he's got to be able to
get the ball to him I think they
probably should try some shorter passes
from higher percentage passes and let
Josh run with the ball afterwards and
try to get that percentage up for both
of them and his cars are playing for his
job
now that Sachi Braun is out and that
night one would think that a new general
manager
with what looks like to be the first
overall pick is coming in with all those
quarterbacks coming out Mary Kay yes yes
this one is playing for his job there's
no question about it I even asked you
Jackson that the other day you know
isn't it a foregone conclusion you kind
of have to draft a quarterback and he
said you can't have too many good
quarterbacks on this team we need to
have that kind of a problem and I do
think that they will direct one and in
Bashan has four games to prove that he
still deserves a chance ask Mary Kay
Cabot the poll question before we let
her go Christopher Brockman all right
Mary who which team in the NFL gets it
right first the Browns Giants Jets or
bucks
what do you think hmm great question I
think the Jets already on their way
okay okay that's one so what else you
got what do you think no I want you to
with which one do you think is gonna get
it first after the Jets then yeah see
other jobs after the Jets
you know what what let's say that I'm
gonna say the Cleveland Browns now that
they made this move I think they're
gonna have a chance okay thank you Mary
Kay I appreciate it you take care of
yourself thank you guys you got it
there's Mary Kay cannon the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience